Laurent liiss maître artisan verrier
d'art installé à sainemt de Touren je
travaille le verre thermoformé le
thermoformage c'est la mise en forme du
verre par la chaleur donc j'utilise un
four avec des cycles de cuisson qui
correspond exactement à la cuisson du
verre et de ce que je veux en faire
comme
objet la température du thermoformage
c'est suivant le résultat qu'on veut 830
850° après c'est les courbes de cuisson
qui différencient en fonction de
l'épaisseur et la surface du verre je
travaille principalement de l'objet de
décoration l'art de la table ainsi que
des trophées pour les associations pour
les
municipalités je travaille avec des
décorateurs d'intérieur des architectes
d'intérieur pour réaliser des demandes
bien précises de la part des clients je
trava les petits plateaux à fromage de
chèvre les dessus de Bari et les
aménagements intérieurs pour les
viticulteurs les châteaux les offices de
tourisme c'est très très large en fait
voilà c'est du plâtre donc comme c'est
souple et ben le platre il va se lisser
tout seul je suis également élu référent
métier d'art à la Chambre des Métiers au
niveau départemental ainsi qu'au niveau
régional et je représente donc tous les
artisans d'art du territoire la
problématique c'est que beaucoup
d'artisans d'art ne vivent pas
pleinement de leur passion donc c'est
assez comp
de de pouvoir gérer son métier respectif
que ça soit les céramistes les verriers
les tailleurs de pierre je pense qu'il
faut que les artisans d'art se
rassemblent pour pouvoir maintenir cette
activité aux yeux du grand public
et et pour pouvoir survivre et on est
plus fort en groupe que tout seul